mes chers compatriotes je voudrais
d'abord exprimer ma sympathie à toutes
celles et à tous ceux qui vivent ces
derniers jours de
1999 dans
l'épreuve je pense au N victimes de la
tempête et à toutes les familles
endeuillées dont nous partageons la
peine je pense à nos concitoyens
cruellement touchés dans leur vie
quotidienne à ceux dont les biens ont
été détruits à ceux qui craignent pour
leur activité et leur emploi à ceux qui
souffrent de voir notre patrimoine notre
littoral nos forêts nos monuments
défigurés je voused mon
émotion mais aussi ma fierté devant
l'exceptionnel élan de solidarité qui
anime tant de bénévoles et
d'association mobilisé au côté des
services publics civils et militaires et
des
élus en ces heures difficiles nous
ressentons profondément la fragilité des
choses la précarité de ce qui nous
semblait acquis nous voyons combien tout
peut être parfois remis en cause du fait
de l'inconscience des hommes ou du
déchaînement des éléments
naturels nous mesurons aussi
l'importance du rôle de l'État dans
notre
société un état sur lequel pèsent des
responsabilités essentielles le service
public la sécurité la
solidarité un état auquel il appartient
de prévoir de faire face d'assurer la
coordination des moyens du
pays nous mesurons surtout le prix de
l'aide
fraternel du soutien spontané de la main
tendue qui sont le ciment même de la
nation au moment où nous touchons aux
portes de l'an
2000 rien n'est décidément plus moderne
plus nécessaire plus
solide que le sentiment d'appartenir à
une même communauté et d'être
responsable les uns des
autres la France blessé veut se
retrouver rassemblé et
fraternel parce que nos compatriotes ont
toujours su dans l'épreuve faire parler
leur cœur je voudrais dire merci à tous
les
Français ce soir nous vivons ensemble un
moment fort et
singulier ce qui paraissait très
lointain et qui a longtemps symbolisait
le futur l'an 2000 est devenu
contemporain
immédiat je suis sûr que beaucoup
d'entre vous vont vivre ces instants
avec un peu d'émotion un peu
d'étonnement une certaine appréhension
parfois née du sentiment que s'achève
une époque dont on possédait les clés
dont on maîtrisait les règles et les
habitudes je comprends ces mouvements de
l'âme pourtant j'ai confiance la France
franchira les obstacles comme elle l'a
toujours fait au long de son histoire
pour peu qu'elle soit fidèle à
elle-même même si le passé est bien
présent dans notre mémoire je ne
m'attarderai pas sur le siècle qui
s'achève siècle de progrès sans
précédent pour la santé l'éducation les
conditions de vie pour les libertés la
vie démocratique la situation des femmes
les
solidarités mais aussi siècles d'horreur
de tragédie de
convulsion qui a vu deux guerres
mondiales le goulag les dictatures
totalitaires et la
Choa mais ce soir ce qui importe c'est
l'avenir notre avenir celui de nos
enfants le progrès va se poursuivre avec
ces
hésitations avec ses limites que nous
mesurons bien face aux événements
récents qui nous invitent à
l'humilité progrès de la science progrès
des communications entre les hommes
progrès de la
médecine un grand nombre des enfants qui
vont naître cette année verront l'an
2100 ces
progrès ne prendront tout leur sens que
s'il bénéficie à l'homme à tous les
hommes le 21e siècle doit être le siècle
de
l'éthique je sais que bien les tragédies
aujourd'hui font douter de cette
espérance pourtant de plus en plus les
nations s'accordent pour mieux faire
respecter les droits de l'homme
pour défendre la liberté et la dignité
humaine un nouvel ordre international
s'affirme peu à peu demain il ne devra
plus y avoir de repos pour les criminels
contre l'humanité et au nom de la France
en votre nom c'est le combat difficile
que je mène chaque
jour à l'intérieur de chaque
nation une exigence se fait entendre
toujours plus forte pour que les
avancées de la science soient orientées
vers le bien de l'homme et ne se
retourne jamais contre lui je pense par
exemple aux manipulations génétiques ou
au
clonage de même dans le domaine de
l'environnement les peuples ne veulent
plus que la course à la productivité
épuise la planète la responsabilité
de tous ceux qui dans le monde
dégradeent le patrimoine naturel doit
être recherché et sanctionné car il
s'agit du patrimoine que nous larons à
nos
enfants même si le monde change comme il
n'a jamais changé la modernité ne doit
pas nous diviser
elle doit profiter à
chacun nous réussirons nous réussirons
parce que nous avons pris des décisions
qui engagent et qui garantissent notre
avenir nous avons choisi ensemble de
faire grandir la France dans l'Europe
une Europe qui nous garantit la paix une
Europe qui nous permet de peser
davantage dans le
monde nous avons choisi aussi de prendre
part à la mondialisation
d'enprendre toute notre part mais une
mondialisation maîtrisée organisée
respectueuse de
l'environnement capable de prendre en
compte les aspirations des hommes et
capable de faire reculer la
pauvreté ce sera tout le sens du combat
de la France dans les grandes
négociations à
venir mes chers
compatriotes nous avons en commun
certaines
valeurs la volonté de donner à chacun sa
chance pour que notre société soit plus
alente plus mobile plus
optimiste l'exigence de solidarité une
solidarité plus responsable où chacun
s'efforcerait de prendre sa part du
contrat l'attachement à la famille parce
qu'elle est chaleur
entraide
sécurité le désir d'être utile de
trouver sa place dans la société de
donner autour de soi de se
réaliser la
qui ne doit pas être renoncement à ses
convictions mais respect de l'autre
l'esprit républicain et le sens de
l'intérêt général qui impose que l'État
conserve toute sa place pour dire le
droit le faire respecter avec autorité
avec
justice gardons ces
exigences gardons ses valeurs en les
faisant vivre nous nous serons plus
forts pour aborder les temps qui
viennent la France change
elle doit le faire au rythme du monde en
étant fidèle à son génie propre elle
serura conjuguer le changement et la
cohésion sociale l'esprit d'initiative
et la sécurité la modernité et le bien
vivre
ensemble mes chers
compatriotes je mesure l'honneur et la
responsabilité
qui m'échoua de m'adresser à vous ce
soir alors que notre nation franchit le
cap du
siècle la France a plus de 1000 ans
riche de fièvre de passion
d'enthousiasme
elle continue commière à ouvrir et à
défricher les chemins du monde le
nouveau siècle est à
inventé plus fraternel plus volontaire
il aura les couleurs que nous lui
donnerons la France sera ce que nous
voudrons qu'elle soit une nation unie
vivante solidaire ouverte qui n'accepte
aucune
fatalité car dans un monde où rien n'est
figé l'avenir dépend de nous l'avenir
dépend de notre capacité à construire à
créer à rêver ensemble les voies de
l'aventure
humaine à chacune et à chacun entre vous
Françaises et Français de métropole
d'outrema de l'étranger je souhaite très
chaleureusement une bonne et une
heureuse année